suda51 is known for titles like No More  Heroes and let it die but he also has  quite the idea for a Mario game I'm Tony  this is a GameSpot news update and to  hear all the crazy game pitches be sure  to subscribe i GN asked sudha about his  idea which involves mario rescuing his  brother Luigi instead of Princess Peach  he said so this really bad guys captured  Luigi so Mario and Koopa become friends  and they go together it's like a road  movie in a car so they go from the south  to the north and just go through it like  through America I think it would be  great to make a Mario game like that  suda51 zai dia might never come to  fruition but for now you can look  forward to Super Mario Odyssey the next  Mario game dropping this holiday on  switch form or switch coverage you can  check out our livestream of one to  switch featuring all sorts of goofiness  and for all the latest on Mario you're  already in the right place